let's play a game some word association
I'm going to say two words and you tell
me the first thing that pops into your
mind does that sound okay all right here
we go tighty whities Walter White yeah
you know a lot of what you hear when
people talk about TV nowadays like
post-breaking bad
is about writing and about the writing
or the decisions that writers make but
television is a visual medium and
introducing your main character and
nothing but his underwear is a choice
and I do Wonder because I was hoping
that was the way you would answer that
question
what is this particular type of
underwear bring to mind for you I have a
connection to them since I wore them as
a child but what do you think when you
see this what does this tell you about a
character
well for me I think of it as something
that like a middle-aged dad type gets in
his stocking for Christmas uh every year
I also think of you know like children
something that little little boys wear
they're sort of no-nonsense No Frills
very matter of fact very practical
clothing Choice yeah you know when I
think about it I think it it was the
only choice when you were a kid for me
it was my only choice and you know I
grew up
and then I got to make a decision of
what kind of underwear I was going to
wear because I would you know as you get
older you think hey
people are going to see me without my
pants on I'm going to take them off and
and they're going to see what I'm
wearing and it's one of the things that
jumps out at me right away about this
show and something that that resonates
and stays with me tighty whities are a
choice
they're a choice not to make a choice
does that make sense very much so it's a
really great point and I think it tells
us a lot about the character of Walter
White exactly
tell me why you're doing this
seriously
why do you do it money
mainly
there you go nah come on if you've gone
crazy
or something I mean if you've if
you're crazy
pressed I'm
that
something I need to know about
okay I mean that that affects me
I am awake
what
hello welcome to growth Decay
transformation I'm Pete and I'm Courtney
and this is our Breaking Bad re-watch
retrospective podcast we've already done
a short introductory episode to explain
why we decided to do this type of series
and why we wanted to do it right now
and I think you should go listen to that
before you listen to this episode if you
haven't already because it does give you
a lot of more information about what
we're trying to do here
but as I said on Pete peppers I make
videos on my YouTube channel of the same
name and I love TV that's really what
this podcast is about because sometimes
this is a love hate relationship but not
when it comes to this little Underdog
Show Breaking Bad this is a one show
that I can definitely say that
I absolutely love and haven't really
gotten tired of not even 15 years later
it was one of the first scripted series
that came out on a network that wasn't
on anyone's radar at the time it's one
of my favorite shows and the story of
how it came into existence how the world
and the characters and everyone just
sort of got sucked into it if it didn't
change television the television
landscape changed with it over at 62
episode run
and these are all things that I can get
excited to talk about the thing about
breaking bad is it took all the stuff
that I liked about TV and it used them
it didn't reinvent the wheel necessarily
but it added its own crucial ingredients
and it made something better so what
about you who are you and what are you
doing here hi I'm Courtney uh some of
you may know me from my YouTube channel
court news reviews and I am also a huge
fan of Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul
and TV in general and with the 15th
anniversary of the premiere of the pilot
episode on January 20th of this year
2023 and With Better Call Saul having
just wrapped up last year it seemed like
a really good time to revisit the series
now now that we have an entire story a
complete story to consider now that
being said you should know that this is
going to be a full Spoilers Podcast it's
intended for people who have seen both
shows and already know what happens so
if you're new to the series and you
don't want to be spoiled this is not
going to be the right podcast for you I
think you should go and watch these two
fantastic series for yourself and Jim
and Aeron have a podcast called breaking
good that covers breaking bad as it
aired that you can listen to if you're
looking for a Companion podcast as you
watch for the first time then you should
come back and listen to us after you've
finished
with all that out of the way let's dive
into this Courtney can you give us a
nice summary of what happens in the
pilot episode of Breaking Bad which
premiered on January 20th 2008 and was
written and directed by series Creator
Vince Gilligan the only episode he wrote
alone
sure yeah so the series begins in
Albuquerque New Mexico it's September 7
2008 and that's Walter White played by
Brian Cranston that's his 50th birthday
and we learned in this episode that Walt
is a high school chemistry teacher who
works a second job at a car wash he's
married to Skyler played by Anna Gunn he
has a teenage son who has cerebral palsy
Walter Jr played by RJ Mitty and a
surprise baby on the way after he gets
diagnosed with stage three lung cancer
and tells no one he decides to take the
offer of a ride along from his DEA agent
brother-in-law Hank played by Dean
Norris and a spies a former student flee
the scene of the methbus that he writes
along to he later approaches that
student Jesse Pinkman played by Aaron
Paul and they team up to make and sell
meth Walt steal some equipment from his
school science lab they buy an RV to
serve as their mobile meth lab and when
they're out of cooking Jesse tries to
bring in a distributor to help move
their product but then things go awry
very quickly indeed
yeah so we decided that we'll start each
episode of our podcast by briefly
discussing our overall impressions of
the episode so Pete what did you think
what are your overall impressions of the
pilot well it's a really strong way to
start a series
one of the best Pilots that I can think
of
um definitely up on any list of of TV
show Pilots I think what really stands
out to me on the re-watch though is what
a great job they did introducing this
character
and how they threaded that needle of
making us warm up to him care about him
you know sort of be on his side
but then subtly introducing some of the
darkness that's there under the surface
that we won't pick up on until much
later
Walter White has to come off as pathetic
he has to be someone that we feel sorry
for
but he also has to be capable
because otherwise whenever he goes off
and makes all these bad decisions and
he's out there in the Underworld like
this journey that he takes through the
criminal underworld he has to be
competent enough for us like for that to
seem plausible that is possible that
this guy could do that so he has to be
two things and I think they do a
fantastic job of of of doing that you
know of creating that I mentioned that
this is an Underdog Story and that's
very much how you interact with him in
the beginning
do you see him as this guy he's got a
you know he had a raw deal he's not even
a smoker but he got lung cancer
um you know so he's he's he's he's he's
someone that you that you're you're
you're you're trained to think hey this
guy he he deserves better
and
that's how you know you he you interact
with him as a underdog that you want to
root for in spite of all the terrible
decisions he makes and who doesn't love
an underdog and I like how the show
itself is kind of in that same you know
has that same disposition in some ways
it should have never made it to TV it
should have never been as popular as it
was you know the the ratings were pretty
bad early on it didn't catch on you know
naturally like some of these shows that
we we watch now so it it it's all pretty
fantastic and it makes me really excited
to talk about it here here yeah I
completely agree with everything you
said and
um Walt as an underdog is yeah someone
that that the audience immediately
relates to and you want to see succeed
and plus we get all that behind the
scenes stuff about him where you see
just uh how life has kicked him around
and he just keeps getting one Raw Deal
after another so we're definitely
rooting for him by the end of it and
what really uh stood out to me in in
this episode
um certainly on the upon the re-watch is
just how well established the characters
are from the outset and how we're
essentially told everything that we
really need to know about Waltz and and
his world and really his trajectory in
this pilot so um the growth and Decay
and transformation of this character are
all foreshadowed really beautifully and
I also think that the power dynamics of
the show are really really well conveyed
in this pilot episode and uh among
Walton and each of his family members so
like how Skyler his wife is cast as the
one who wears the pants in the family
she organizes the family's finances
um sort of tells him what to do sort of
thing and then uh Waltz is rather
passive
um at least leading up to his diagnosis
right he's just kind of like a go along
to get along kind of guy and then you
have Hank who you know the foil of the
show to Walt is this hyper masculine
character and also of course Jesse and
Walt's power dynamics but really the the
gender gender Dynamics are what really
stood out to me upon re-watching it and
specifically like the role of of
masculinity and so we see how Walt's
masculinity is like constantly
challenged throughout this this episode
but he starts to reclaim his power in
several important ways and there are
three key moments I think in this
episode so um the first of the car wash
when he quits the car wash and he grabs
himself you know after wipe down this
yeah exactly and bogdan's trying to get
him to to go outside and and do wipe
downs and then um at the clothing store
where uh they're picking out new pants
for Walter Jr and these uh teenage kids
start making fun of Walter Jr and you
know making fun of them needing to try
on his big boy pants and stuff like that
and then Walt comes in and
um you know confronts that kid and he uh
you know he's taking his power back in
that moment and in asserting himself and
then uh finally at the end of the
episode right in bed with Skyler that's
how the episode closes when he flips her
over so they're not even in like
missionary position it's a power move
and uh so much so that where she's like
Walter is that you you know
is that you and it and it's interesting
because not really right that that in
that one episode in the the one hour of
TV
um he becomes someone else and and that
really underlines that at the end and
and I I do I agree with all of what
you're saying there I do find those to
be to be really important things one
thing that stands out uh knowing how all
these characters develop is is
you know I I said I think it's one of
the best Pilots of all time and I and I
stand by that
where it it does come up short a little
bit I think is with these other
characters their Walt is so so well
um developed and and just so compelling
it kind of makes the rest of them all
look uh
uh a little I mean I I find Hank you
know Hank was was completely
uninteresting in a way I mean he was
annoying you know he seemed like who is
this guy nobody really acts like that
but yeah they do so that's that's super
terrible and annoying at you know and um
Jesse he he he wasn't he he's not
compelling in the way that he ends up
being
um
but yeah so I think what you see in this
last minute in in in with the hindsight
of having watched the whole series is
yeah these things aren't aren't perfect
but they do they are really effective at
making the points they're supposed to
make Hank is is over
he's overdrawn in a way
um and that is because he is the
opposite of what Walter White is he you
know in almost every point in every
every way you can think of and as you
mentioned
you know with his ex with with Walt's
his connection to his son and the way
that his son looks up to Hank we see
that right from the very beginning how
that that's something that that really
bothers him it's something it's a dark
there's something dark in there and um
yeah it's I I think that that last part
where we see him
you know his first change his first the
first place where we see that he's
because he's he's confronted with this
situation where he got away with
what they were doing he you know he he
killed people as far as he knows
um none of this is
stuff that you run into in your day as a
high school chemistry teacher like he's
in a brand new world
and he went through
a process of it starts a process I
should say I guess of these dominoes
falling this cascading effects that are
going to happen because of this one
decision he makes and so so to see him
like you said take control it really is
kind of triumphant instead of you know
what what it will turn out to be it
really feels kind of triumphant like
hell yeah
this guy is is all right with me you
know yeah sure and of course I mean I
feel like we should probably note that
it's like the illusion of control right
so he's feeling powerful in his life but
there's um there's High moments and low
moments so anytime things start to go
his way uh there's always a dark moment
right so like he there they get the RV
things are going well they make the meth
and of course crazy eight and Emilio
come up and then things get a little bit
out of control
um but but the I think a lot of what
we're sort of circling around is Walt's
perception of himself and I think that's
also really important in how this
episode is written and directed so you
just noted that you don't think a lot of
some of the other characters are as well
um conceived or developed as Walters and
of course I mean he is our our main
character in this episode and um as as
you noted also this was the first
episode that Vince Gilligan wrote all by
himself and uh he has later you know
talked about how it was a to everyone's
credit that he got a writer's team to
help you know flesh out some of these
points and details and things like that
but thinking of of sympathizing also
with with Walter White's point of view
as the underdog we're being shown a very
specific point of view and it is Walt's
point of view
um and I think that towards the end of
the series that starts to unravel a
little bit like hopefully viewers start
to become a little bit more objective as
they're watching him and really seeing
that what he has presented and what we
have been presented has been his idea of
himself and it's not exactly like the
kind of guy that he presents himself to
be and on that point there are a couple
of like visual cues that I just wanted
to point out really quickly that stood
out to me upon re-watching that I don't
think I really noticed the first time I
watched and uh that's in the the nursery
in their house in Holly's room which is
a converted office and uh we see
um in and like the first uh shot after
the the teaser the cold open of the
episode we see him get up in the morning
and he's on his little sad step cleaner
climber thing and we see like the
diapers and the crib and all that stuff
getting prepared for the birth of the
baby and we get a shot of like I think
it's like a box of some kind and it says
Safety First on it and it lingers the
camera lingers just long enough for for
you to notice it and then later in the
clothing store scene that I already
talked about the name of that clothing
store is family first so we get these
ideas that Walt is a a practical
sensible person that he believes in in
safety and family and stuff like that we
also get that when in that exchange with
Jesse when they're at Jesse's house
loading up the trunk with all of the
equipment and stuff like that and he's
talking about how they're gonna wear
safety gear and eye goggles and have
um an eye wash it will be safety first
so it's this illusion of control and the
solution of this man who is a safe
cautious man and as cuspring will later
tell him you are not a cautious man you
know but uh I think we start to sort of
realize that a little bit especially
looking at the re-watching this he's he
makes a lot of mistakes and he's not as
cautious or as sensible as he likes to
think he is
which is which is is is all of us right
I mean that's what's compelling about it
is
you know we think of ourselves in a way
the world sees us in a different way and
then somewhere in between all of that is
the truth of Who We Are
right yeah
so yeah so I I think it's an interesting
take that
those characters were were essentially
seeing them the way that Walter White
sees them exactly the way that they are
yet and that makes sense especially
as we've said that this is Vince writing
just the the pilot and and the you know
he has this idea in his mind that he
wants to make a TV show where the
character changes
but the the full trajectory hasn't been
hasn't been figured out they don't you
know he's he's he's trying to thread
that needle that I mentioned earlier of
making us like the character making us
root for the character
but also saying hey you know there's
some other stuff going on here that you
might want to you want to check out as
we get to know him a little bit better
yeah so with that said let's go back to
the beginning and this talk about this
idea of the pre-credits teaser and you
know the cold open and how it sets the
tone not just for the episode but the
entire show because this isn't something
that was new TV shows had done these
sorts of things
um soap operas I think especially did
this and you know they also were in you
know you also hear a lot of stuff about
breaking bad being serialized that also
is something that um
soap operas were doing for a long time
and with great success to their their
target demo
this is uh I think the thing about cold
opens and teasers when you talk about
breaking bad and then later brighter
Call Saul is that they did them better
than anyone else and and this is uh not
something that I thought about the first
time I watched it but something that did
absolutely work I it asks the question
who is this guy why is he in this
situation
and um then it goes and it answers some
of that which is a good sign it makes
you think like okay well you're gonna
you have to pay attention to you have to
pay attention to what's happening in
this show and it feels like it might
actually pay off you don't really know
because at this time TV doesn't have a
great track record of that I don't think
um visually it sets up a lot of the
visual language for the show that
they'll they'll stick to it it has a
this one of the things that's great
about this show is the way that it looks
and the way that it feels it it it it
develops the world visually that was
sort of what I was talking about with
the tighty whities before
and you get all of that within this
first opening teaser yeah you absolutely
do and it's I I think of the landscape I
think of Albuquerque
um the Sandia Mountains that hold desert
landscape as being a really integral
character in the show itself and um I
think when I first watched it it's one
of the things that that initially
grabbed me about it because it was
different it was unique it's filmed on
scene right so you have this sort of
almost Cinema fairy tale like uh aspect
to it that you did not really see in a
lot of TV shows at the time for sure and
uh again as you were just talking about
the the cold open Pete I was thinking
about again like how it sets the the
tone not just for like uh the action and
um the the visual landscape of it but
also uh speaking again to a little bit
about how Walter sees himself so I'm
thinking specifically of the moment when
he grabs Jesse's camcorder and he's
recording himself um and he's he says
you know this is a message for my wife
and my son and he tells them I you're
gonna find out some things about me but
you should know I only ever did this for
you I had you in my heart the whole time
and again there's that sort of
self-delusion uh hinted at in the very
first couple minutes of the entire
series I think is so interesting right
and he's like you know he has this this
personal narrative of of himself and who
he is and you know he's the good guy he
can't be the bad guy
yeah and and that's that's a good place
to to uh start when we we think about
him who is this guy because he's a
little bit it's a little bit hard to to
put it together in the in the very
beginning
um
the one thing that I I guess that that
we see
for sure is that he has a passion for
for chemistry there's two moments in
this episode where you see him really
look alive and engaged and and just
excited and they both are directly
related to chemistry he when he's given
the the speech to his students about
what chemistry is where we got the name
for this podcast the growth Decay
transformation
he nobody's listening to him he he's not
really getting through he's not
effective in his his role there
and but you could see that it's he still
has that spark when he's talking when he
when he's when he's giving this when
he's putting that out there and the
other time that you see it
um is whenever he's talking about the
glassware that he stole from from the
um high school that he's he's showing it
to Jesse who Jesse isn't isn't impressed
at all but he's he's like he's really
fired up about that round bottom flask
you know he he just he just is like you
know and and and and that's and I I
really like that I really like the way
those things come through
at this point you know in my
relationship with the show as like
because all right so he he's supposed to
be pathetic right I mean yeah that's
what we're supposed to get from from all
this stuff the stair climber nothing
glamorous about that
um waking up he wakes up before the
alarm goes off he
he just seems uh you know aim like
beyond beyond just what the reality of
things like he he has a low paying job
um he has to take a second job all of
that stuff
but I mean just even in his in his
personal details the car he drives the
the the clothes he wears it's all it's
all pretty forgettable stuff yeah yeah
yeah I think he's very much painted and
as you say this way meant to be sort of
pathetic so he he wakes up early it's
his 50th birthday right and um you know
when that that first shot I talked a
little bit about already when he's on
the little stair climber thing we see on
the wall that there's a plaque that was
given to him from contributing to
research on like uh some sort of
chemistry project that he was working on
that that led to a Nobel Prize and
um you know then he's he goes to the
breakfast table and his wife is making
them eat veggie bacon which Junior tells
us smells like Band-Aids you know and
he's got a little bit one of the
funniest lines of of the uh pilot
episode yeah for sure and um you know so
it's just kind of like sad it's his
birthday and like he's eating in this
this gross bacon or whatever and his son
is giving them
giving them some I guess he's upset that
the water heater isn't working so again
we get a sense of like the financial
struggles that they're they're dealing
with the lack of um hot water in the
house
and um Skyler I think it's at the scene
where she tells him that you know she
asked what time he'll be home and she's
like I don't want him [__] you around
talking about Bogdan at the car wash
like she wants him home at this exact
time so you get this the sense of him
that that he's he works hard and uh he
he's doing the best that he can and um
as I said earlier just sort of rolling
with the punches he's just kind of going
through life like there's really not
much exciting going on for him until we
see him in the classroom and he is
talking about chemistry as you were just
describing Pete and he's he just gives
it he gives the definition of chemistry
and um that that moment really stood out
to me uh because it's also telling us
the viewers how we can watch the show
this is a study of change you're going
to watch this man change we're gonna
watch him grow Decay transform and I
love the the line that he says at the
end of that little Spiel he goes it's
fascinating and then we see the rest of
the classroom and they're not paying
attention at all so nobody's interested
yeah nobody's interested in this man and
we're shown a man as you were saying
this very for you know sort of
forgettable he's Bland his clothing is
Bland he doesn't really stand out at his
birthday party he is not the star of the
show at all Hank dominates the
conversation but uh just wait and see
because he is going to become very
fascinating right it is fascinating to
watch this transformation take place
over the next uh you know 62 episodes
and that's one of the things that I look
forward to uh talking about as we go as
we go through them because
it it does change after you know how the
story ends
um we you know in the beginning we do
we do root for him and by the end not so
much
so when you watch it again it that that
that veil has been lifted we know who he
he is pretty much
but it doesn't make his character any
less interesting or compelling and um
it's funny because one of the things one
of the things TV has always done is it
when something works
because I guess if we you know if we
talk about like the network system when
there was only a handful of networks and
um they were all
competing for the same ad you know those
those High uh visibility ad times or or
whatever however they do that
one show would come out and it would be
novel in a way that really caught
people's attention
so everybody else would copy that so
you'd have like the the
three three different versions of the
same story and uh
that's how that's what viewers got to
choose between and so part of the part
of the the thing that came out of this
era of TV that what you would call The
Golden this golden age of television
was this type of character man who um
you know was was an anti-hero started
out as an anti-hero and
um so it it got done to death and people
are kind of tired of that but one of the
things that this show
is one of the ways that this show stands
out to me
even even now is that it's not so much
that it is uh it's celebrating him it
doesn't it doesn't celebrate this this
transformation of
into his worst self and and him getting
what he wants through through being a
terrible person through violence and
everything else yeah I mean to your
point he loses everything right like we
get to see real time the consequences
and the Fallout of his choices yeah so
it's more of a
I don't know how to what's the best word
for like
it takes it apart it looks at the
situation it's not even a little bit
political as far as TV shows go it's
really just being a television show a
character based
exploration of this of this archetype
and I think it's I think it just it's
just a lot better than than what many of
the um the other ones even the other
really good ones are in comparison yeah
yeah so I you mentioned this this golden
age of of television and um we we've
done a little bit of research into this
and so at the that this critical time
period in the 2000s right which is it
really a lot of Scholars that have
talked about it sort of cite the late
90s going up to about
um 2010 early 2010s uh where we had this
revolution the second golden age in
television and um you know there were a
lot of different things that that had to
fall into place for this to happen so we
had the move from analog to digital
Television right so like we had higher
quality TVs and
um flat screens and HD TVs coming in and
all that uh and so that all helped
contributed it contribute to the I think
the success of this particular show and
why it made it possible for them to
create what they did with this and then
of course also with like the Advent of
like Netflix really helping it and stuff
like that but I I tend to agree with you
Pete that they do it better than anyone
else
um I think The Sopranos are great don't
get me wrong but that's HBO and HBO has
bigger budgets you know they've always
been able to produce bigger better
things and then of course
um AMC uh they Mad Men came out in what
2007 so it was a year before the
Breaking Bad premiere and I was
listening to an interview with Vince
Gilligan he was talking to The Writers
Guild in 2010 and he was talking about
how uh his his process of pitching uh
Breaking Bad to the Denver networks and
pretty much everyone turned them down
right uh a couple of them liked it but
they couldn't they couldn't uh you know
go go forward with it so he told this
really funny story really quickly about
um TNT and how when he met with the two
execs there they were like in love with
it they were going crazy and they're
like there's no way we can buy this show
we'll get fired and they're like unless
you make him can we make him not be a
meth cook can we have him like be a
counterfeiter or something and then but
but Vince fortunately for all of us you
know stuck to his guns and he was like
no I really want it to be this way so he
had conceived it in a very particular
way and I'm glad he was able to find AMC
but when he met with AMC and uh because
at the time they had not started uh
filming Mad Men yet like Mad Men had not
come out when he first met with them to
pitch I believe they I believe they they
had they own uh Mad Men that was their
first Cryptid show but they hadn't even
started making it yet whenever they
brought Breaking Bad when they bought
breaking or you know decided to go with
them which is pretty amazing when you
think about it now yeah exactly and so
when Vince tells the story about meeting
with them you know he thought it was a
complete like joke right and so he
agreed to meet with them just because he
wanted to get a couple free scotches at
the hotel bar you know figured like you
know they pick up the tab or whatever
and uh and he was like but in his mind
he said uh that he thought he would
probably have better luck pitching
Breaking Bad to the Cooking Channel you
know something since the show about
cooking so yeah it's uh it's really
interesting about like what was
happening in the landscape at that
particular moment though to make all of
these really great shows possible and I
think with Breaking Bad and I don't
really want to talk so much about the
other shows and you know dissect those
as much here but I think one of the
things with Breaking Bad that it has
this sort of universal appeal right it
became really popular globally so it's
not
um only relevant to Americans right uh
or even relevant to its time period so I
recently watched Sopranos actually for
the first time because I did not watch
it when it was on air and I really
enjoyed it I think it's a really well
made show it's great and everything but
I don't know that I would want to
re-watch it where with Breaking Bad I
keep returning to it over and over again
so I think it has this uh this the
staying power right like just like how
you would revisit your favorite film or
reread a favorite book I think it's one
of those things that that holds up over
time yeah and a lot of what you're
saying there about the the network
situation and some of the different
things that happened as they as this
that made that were essential in this
show coming to to the TV and becoming
what it was at the time they're all it's
all pretty fascinating too there's a
there's a nice parallel between Walter's
decision and how things like he doesn't
become just an evil character overnight
he he makes a decision and
there's this Cascade of of of things
that happens as you know like I think I
mentioned earlier you know Domino's The
Dominoes start to fall and and
it the show itself kind of has that same
same backstory when you really dig into
it they're coming to a network that that
has this trying to make a name for
itself and and it it's just
um it's just a a matter of luck that
they they they're just hands off with it
they just say okay this is what you want
to make we'll let you make it because
that doesn't really seem to happen
anywhere else ever I mean maybe
well you know whenever David Lynch made
the return Twin Peaks the return they
let him do whatever he wanted there
um but for the most part it doesn't
sound like that's that's that's typical
and um in this case it really made it
sound a lot better and one of my
favorite stories about that
is the way that we uh we had talked
about how the the the ratings weren't
great at first and one of those one of
those one of those funny uh
circumstances is that they had
originally planned to air this after the
NFC championship game which is the
second most popular football game on TV
all year only behind the Super Bowl so
they're they're really expecting that
they're going to get this male
viewership demographic that's really
important to them to already be on and
they'll just transition from watching
the game into watching this brand new
show that they've been promoting
and it turns out that the game went into
overtime and it's like
super rare like it only happened a few
times in the history of of the NFL and
and so
if they did if they did do what they
were hoping would happen they they came
into the show 15 minutes late or
something like that and and it just goes
to show you know how how how things have
to sort of break the right way for a
show and and then
it just it just turns out that this show
was so good that even when they broke
the wrong way it was able to have such a
strong lead character he went out and
and won some Emmys uh for his
performance and and that was enough to
keep it on the air long enough until
people caught up and and and
you know got to got to get sucked in
like we all have at this point right
yeah that is that's funny though about
the football game what I was gonna say
I've already kind of talked about it the
role that Netflix really really played
in helping to promote the show and so
AMC of course pushes back against that a
little bit but even Vince Gilligan
himself has you know credited Netflix
for the major boost that the series got
so they um put the first uh Four Seasons
on ahead of the fifth season airing on
AMC and I was one of those people that
discovered Breaking Bad through Netflix
like I was already aware of it being on
but it was already in the third or
fourth season when people in my circle
my networks were talking about it and I
didn't have a DVR at the time so I
didn't really have a way to catch up
with it um I guess maybe they were
showing like uh marathons or something
like like AMC does on weekends but
that's not exactly convenient unless you
yeah VHS or or DVR the whole thing when
it's on yeah so being able to get caught
up on Netflix was was huge uh and really
I think helped to drive some of that
success but it also already had like
Word of Mouth cred at that point like it
was a critical darling so you mentioned
some of the the Emmys and the pilot was
nominated for a bunch and they won two
so Brian Cranston actually won an Emmy
for his performance in the pilot episode
and Lynn Willingham uh the the uh the
editor sorry the editor of the episode
also won an Emmy for her work on this
particular uh episode and so when we
were we're talking just to backtrack a
little bit talking about the the Golden
Age of Television one of the other
really I think interesting things about
breaking bad was the sort of talent that
they were able to pull in behind the
scenes for this like you know unknown
Network show so like having John Toll as
a cinematographer on the pilot is is
really I think exciting and interesting
and and what they were able to do with
TV he's the only person to win
back-to-back Oscars is that correct yeah
yeah for a Braveheart and Legends of the
Fall back to back I mean that's not yeah
that's not nothing that's for sure and
this was his first time uh working on TV
I believe
yeah that's definitely true the thing
that's surprising about this when you
watch it is is only is not how how great
it is but it's how much they even how
much better they even get over the the
the
as the seasons go on right
um like they they're they they start at
a really high point as far as craft is
is concerned and and they just improve
season over season and this goes on all
the way through Better Call Saul for for
that matter and
yeah they they they did really start out
with a a bunch of talented people and it
really comes through even in this first
episode that we're talking about right
now just really quickly the the talk
about the the
um the viewership the pilot had 1.4
million viewers and by the time they got
around to
season five that had six million you
know 5.92 million so that was also
doubling the number from the year before
that for season four so there was
definitely a big Boost after I think the
first three seasons went on Netflix and
people were able to binge them and get
caught up
so obviously that just kept happening
over that next year so yeah there was a
huge boost to them being uh being
available there
and the other thing about it is the
writer strike in their first episode
their first season was was supposed to
be Nine episodes long that was the order
after the they bought the pilot
and because the writer strike the
writer's Guild strike happened
mid-season they had to cut it short to
episode seven and that had a big impact
on the actual story so that that's
pretty fascinating too when you think
about it because if they had done what
they were planning on doing it probably
wouldn't be the same show it wouldn't
have followed the same trajectory it
might have got to the same place but it
would make it would have made a big
difference I think
um yeah sure let's unpack that a little
bit for maybe listeners that don't know
what you're talking about so uh what
Vince had intended to do with the end of
season one before season two but then
the writers strike happened and they had
to they had more time to work on it yeah
I think most people know that that Jesse
was initially supposed to be killed off
in the first season and they changed
their mind whenever Aaron Paul turned
out to be a really strong actor and they
really liked him in the role the other
thing that there is and I guess this is
something we're going to have to figure
out as we go on and hopefully our fans
will our listeners you know they'll
they'll they'll send us emails and let
us know how much of this is is stuff
that they want to hear because we're
there there's a ton of information about
these shows are so popular and and they
have such a you know strong
um there's been such a strong interest
in them for so long there's a lot of
information out there
some people may not have heard some of
this stuff before and we don't want to
just you know hit the most popular
points that people have so we'll just
have to get a feeling for that as we go
on but one of the things about the first
season like when they already had when
it was already in process and they were
they were getting ready to write those
scripts for episode 8 and episode nine
the plan was to have Steve Gomez Hank's
partner
get killed in the final episode and then
that would be and I think it would be
from tuko I mean I don't I don't know
that part for sure but that would put
Walt in a situation where he has to he
wants to help him
but he can't because it'll expose his
identity so he would have another one of
these choices there at the end
and and from what I understand there's
supposed to be this home invasion where
tuko breaks into Walt's house and takes
his family hostage and the series and
the season if I I might be mixing it up
a little bit but the season was supposed
to end with Walt walking down the street
walking down an alley with blood all
over him
and Sirens going off in the background
and you're wondering like how is he
going to get out of this so it's it's a
much different feeling to to the ending
that we actually got there yeah it is
and um we Pete and I we spoke a little
bit about this off
um off air you know uh ahead of
recording this podcast about
um how fortuitous things were for not
just like the landscape of what was
happening in TV and networks and all
that at that exact moment but how like
these little things like the writers
strike uh actually ended up serving the
show in the long run and Aaron Paul
being such a wonderful actor that they
decided to keep him around and other
things like that and um something that I
only recently found out I don't know if
this is common knowledge or not but
there was an interview with Brian
Cranston on James Corden show a couple
weeks ago he's promoting um his his show
your honor I think it's called the one
where he plays the judge and he told
this story about how uh he had the two
final scripts of the series and he had
gone to go hike uh the Sandia Mountains
so he had his car parked out in the
middle of the desert and when he came
back someone had broken into his car and
stolen the two scripts so uh this news
got out right so he Brian Cranston had
to call the the police and you know file
a report and then someone leaked the the
phone call like the recording of him
leaving this message so it became like a
you know a pretty big news story at the
time and Vince Gillian was so paranoid
that he actually changed the the final
two episodes now I don't know how much
he changed them like what details he
changed but he was so afraid of it
leaking that he made some considerable
changes to those those final two
episodes but that being said I think the
finale was pretty perfect I I I'm
there's two things that I I'm gonna be
keeping an eye on as I go through this
um again and that is
the idea that Walt is has always been
Heisenberg and it just comes out because
of the way that it that it happens it's
sort of the the the most popular idea
about what's going on in this series at
the end you know after people watched it
all and and then how the the finale like
the finale is certainly fun it was like
when I watched it the first time it was
it was absolutely it felt satisfying it
felt fun like it's a great hour of
television
I I I I did also kind of have that
feeling like well wait wait a minute
like Walt got everything he wanted at
the end too like when he's able to get
the money to the family and everything
like I I was a little torn on that
especially after the fact so one that's
one of the things that I'll be thinking
about as we go through this how that I
mean because it does make sense and it
and it's satisfying it's just like is it
maybe a little too clean a little too
too satisfying in a way you know like
two did they do a little bit too much to
try to make everything
you know like it because I guess by the
time that we got there I was done with
Walter I wanted to see him die you know
I wanted to see him lose and he does die
but he doesn't necessarily lose so it's
an interesting uh thing to think about
yeah and he absolutely gets to die on
his own terms right I mean he's up
against cancer of course uh and
everything so his time is marked anyway
and we know that from the very first
episode from the pilot episode that this
is a Marked Man and um but he does yeah
he was always going to die so exactly
dying isn't isn't a big deal exactly and
I know
um what you're what you're speaking
about now there's been a lot of
discussion um retrospectively right like
uh yeah did he get off too easy I know
this is something that Vince has talked
a lot about recently like thinking back
um like uh on how they ended the series
should there have been a harsher uh
should there have been harsher
consequences for Waltz uh he gets off
too easy so on and so forth but I can
remember I clearly remember watching the
finale for The the very first time and
being completely satisfied now like up I
think one of the things I'm most
interested in in revisiting this is
seeing how much my feelings about Waltz
have changed how much my ideas about the
series and the trajectory and everything
have have changed and evolved because we
have this whole universe now certainly I
think Better Call Saul adds a lot of
contexts especially how that series
ended and the sort of new narrative that
they've added to it in our understanding
especially of Waltz but also looking at
it from 2023 versus watching it you know
10 15 years ago or whatever of course
knowing how it ends right that's going
to color the way we think of him so you
you sort of hinted a little bit at
probably the biggest debate about the
series was he always bad or does he turn
bad and I think um that's that's going
to be something really exciting to
explore my ideas about this change kind
of constantly and and I I keep coming
back though to the lion growth Decay
transformation and uh was was this guy
always bad and we just see him be
revealed to be this you know Monster for
once of a better word that he really is
or do circumstances and time change him
into that so uh I think in the pilot we
don't get necessarily a sense of that
monstrosity just yet but we do get some
I think it's certainly hinted at there's
some foreshadowing of that like how easy
it is for him to lie you know and how um
especially at the end when um he kills
Emilio and you know that's like an
existential thing when you kill someone
that that you're faced with this thing
that you've done now of course like you
can argue that this was in self-defense
and it absolutely was it was him or him
and Jesse or them right so he did what
he had to do to protect himself but I
think we really get a sense of just how
corrupt he is or the potential for
corruption by how turned on he is by
that so like he uh goes home and that's
that final scene with Skyler in bed it's
it's uh erotic for him and I don't think
it's necessarily like you know he's it's
like a sexual thing as much as it is a
power thing so he's really feeling
powerful for the first time in a very
very long time
um how I mean what's more powerful than
than power over death right so he
himself and that is what he that is what
he lacks in in his life in the beginning
and in his situation with the cancer
diagnosis that's
he has no power over that at all there's
he can it's it's laid out and he and he
reiterates it for us as the audience
that he has maybe two years at best if
he does the chemo
and there's nothing he can do to change
that as far as We Know what you're
saying about power is is something
that's going to come up over and over
again earlier you mentioned when you
were talking
um about how Walt is drawn right and
thinking in terms of power uh you don't
think that the other characters are as
well drawn in this episode and I was
just curious like if if you if you would
tell us a little bit more about your
ideas about the individual characters
about the relationships between Waltz
and his wife and his son and his in-laws
and Jesse
there's a lot that this that any pilot
of any TV show has to do and and I and I
just want to make it before I talk about
that I guess I just want to say that I
think they made the right decision to
focus primarily on Walt and give giving
us what he is so you're asking like what
are were my impressions of the
characters or you know at the time as
watching the pilot or or what exactly do
you are you looking for my biggest
impression from watching this episode
were those relationships and the power
dynamics and how power is like I think
really the the sort of overarching theme
of this episode so it's like someone who
feels very emasculated very powerless
who starts to reclaim his power and then
specifically how that that plays out in
his interpersonal relationships yeah and
I think you do see that in in between
him and Skyler which is something that
that's more relatable I think than than
necessarily like maybe his his
connection to to that we'll learn more
about with um
Hank and Marie and and the other members
of the family she gets a bad rap for for
being overbearing by fans who don't like
her but there's also a question of like
did how did how did that how did that
develop like has he
it because you know there's also the
question of how did he become a teacher
in the first place because there's he
seemed to have a brighter future you
know that that plaque on the wall that
you see uh that you brought up earlier
that that says that he he contributed to
a project that won a Nobel Prize and
then he at some point he makes a
decision to become a high school teacher
and he and he leaves all of that behind
so I think with with Skyler we're we're
meant to think that maybe she is is is
worse than than because of that idea
that you mentioned earlier about we're
seeing it through
Walter's pers you know like we're seeing
it from Walter's perspective she seems a
little overbearing but you know he he's
not he's not taking uh he's passive and
so when you're in a relationship with
with that kind of person someone has to
sort of take over if there's not a
sharing of of that and there's not a
dynamic of like we're both in this
together and or there's not the dynamic
of I'm in charge and and you have to do
what I say then you know somehow that
has to work itself out right yeah yeah
and I I think that's that's such a great
point that you know he lacks initiative
and so I agree that Skyler gets a really
bad rap but again you know that's that's
how we're you know she's presented to us
right and it's it's Walt's point of view
so he's he's very passive and um there
are a couple of things that that
certainly stand out in this episode so
uh the the very sad hand job you know in
bed at night and she's on the computer
uh on eBay right and they're talking
very casually about
uh you know like what they're gonna do
for the weekend she needs him to paint
he wants to go see this uh exhibit on
like the Mars rover photographs or
whatever and you know there she's giving
him this very sad hand job and it's
there's it's so aromantic
um and it's very like almost
transactional in terms of like you know
she's actually trying to sell something
at the moment
um she's on eBay
yeah exactly but the fact that she's
pregnant lets us know that there is
there are moments of intimacy in the
relationship and of course even though
this is kind of a pathetic way to end
his birthday
um it is there are those moments of
connection but yeah in this episode I
very much get the sense that Skyler is
very mothering right she mothers him a
lot she's telling asking him if he took
his echinacea you know we're watching
our cholesterol with the veggie bacon
um we don't use the credit card right
after he uses it to go buy a printer
paper you know she's she's very much the
one that I mean again for for once of a
better word think of her as very much
like a mother figure and I I think that
was something that was deliberate not
just in his relationship
um with the relationship between Skyler
and Walt but were very much meant to
view her as the mother of course she's
pregnant and so you have I mean what's
more motherly than being pregnant at
least in terms of visual representation
and she's just like stay-at-home mom
that's not necessarily a healthy adult
relationship no if your partner is your
mother or your or your father if the if
the if it was you know if it was
rearranged there
yeah but you also but you do you do get
the sense that he's providing right so
like he's working these sort of
lackluster jobs right he's teaching not
I don't mean I'm a teacher myself so
this is not to kill of teachers right I
think it is a very honorable profession
but he's not respected uh and he's he's
sort of squandering his talents right
like because he we know that he's
capable of doing great things in his
actual field but instead he's talking to
a bunch of teenagers who don't care
about what he's talking about and then
working at the car wash so we get the
sense of him doing what needs to be done
in order to provide but uh and and the
question you raised about like what led
him to do this why didn't he go on to do
greater things I think is is of a really
interesting one to ponder like what
actually were the conditions that led up
to this we're never actually explicitly
told why he got into teaching High
School versus maybe you know going into
a university or working elsewhere after
leaving gray matter uh but again I think
this is uh to sort of feed into
narrative right like he's doing what has
to be done he's you know working in
these um
I guess like he's not appreciated in
what he's doing but he's doing it
because he's got to do it to provide and
this uh this idea he has of himself as
providing for his family is one that he
carries on as he starts doing more and
more ridiculous outlandish dangerous
criminal things right I'm doing this to
provide for my family yeah and it's
important this is an important point
because it is it's an absurd premise for
a television show that a mild-mannered
chemistry teacher decides to become a
meth Kingpin it really is it it's not
something that is easy to
buy into in a way you know you hear it
and you think oh that's ridiculous but
then when you watch it and especially
through this episode we're talking about
right now they're able to make it seem
plausible right he's the the thing about
it is is that he's underappreciated
we don't know how much of that is his
fault but it's relatable and I think
that one of the things
because you don't you don't just you
just don't come out of you don't you
just don't wake up one day and and
everything and just make a decision to
say you know what I'm going to be
completely passive I'm going to let life
pass me by I'm going to
I'm going to settle into this life of
mediocrity and and that's it you know I
feel great about it it's something that
happens over time it's something that
develops and because he's faced with
this inciting incident that he has
cancer he has to face that and the
reality that this will be the only thing
that that he he'll he'll be remembered
for right is that he he didn't do much
he uh you know he he he didn't live up
to his potential
that's what other people see and that's
and then you have that internal dialogue
that that that thought the way he sees
himself that we were talking about
earlier but but what's what's
fascinating in a way is that you could
see how he could talk himself into all
these things because he's doing what
you're supposed to do it's a noble
profession yes he doesn't get paid that
much money but it's a job that needs
done and he does it
you know maybe he's not the best maybe
he's not getting through these students
but
somebody has to go there and do this and
he does that and he doesn't make enough
money so he has a second job at the car
wash not everyone would do that
he does
you know so these decisions that he
makes in the way that he ended up the
way he was
it it it's really it's a really an
energy you use the word dissection
earlier it jumped out of me it's it's
really an interesting dissection of
these of this kind of person and it and
it's weird to talk about it because and
this came up when we were talking about
um Kim when she was in Florida in Better
Call Saul it's weird to talk about that
because you're like you're saying oh
this is so pathetic this guy he drives
this this car and he has these bad
clothes and everything else and and he's
just average and and there's nothing
wrong with anybody who does any of those
things you know I mean so it's kind of
weird it's like well yeah that's a good
job actually it doesn't pay as much as
it should but it's still it's it's
responsible it's a thing that you do so
I don't want to say that you know I
don't want people to uh feel bad
whenever we talk about it but we're just
in this particular thing like what the
show is going for is it's giving us this
guy who
he could have been something else and he
got to this place
and then he finds out that you know hey
I don't I'm gonna be out I gotta take it
out of here I'm going to to be gone I'm
not going to leave anything by behind
for my family I have to do something
right and so it's uh it's fantastic yeah
I completely agree so yeah this idea of
him working a thinkless job and
everything and um again I think you said
this really eloquently and it is a
really important Point Pete that like
this isn't to say that teaching is a bad
you know um job to have or anything like
that you know he's living a life that
millions of people live right
um and better than than a lot of people
around the world so on the surface
there's really not much wrong with this
life you know but it's really again this
is his point of view and we later
learned that um you know he was capable
of so much more and I think that's part
of you know his his uh hubris and once
he you know that sort of wakes up right
and start to want to live up to this
potential leave a legacy it's less about
all of the things that he's told himself
he's doing this for like I'm doing it
for my family I'm doing this because
it's the right thing to do and he just
starts doing things for himself
yeah and it all works out perfectly and
everyone lives happily ever after
episode but in the interest of time
we're going to move now to our next
segment and this is when Pete and I talk
about what our favorite line and our
favorite shot of the episode is so Pete
do you want to start tell us what your
favorite line in this episode was
well you kind of just were touching on
it and it's definitely I'm awake when he
says that I love how this feels like
it's sort of a look behind the curtain
of how Walt sees himself that thing
we've been talking about over and over
again and the situation that he finds
himself in like the way he reacts to
that it's one of those things it makes
me think about that idea that everyone
is the hero of Their Own Story because
he's talking about being awake and that
obviously implies that he was asleep and
he's he's coming around to this idea
that he's kind of wasted his life or
whatever but it's like this really you
know fantastic
view of it of like oh well I just had to
wake up and now I can and now I can do
this thing and I can and I can fix
everything and I can go out like a hero
it's really it's really relatable and
it's also just kind of funny the way
that it it comes off and and Jesse
really under does a great job of
underlining that and the way he reacts
by saying what you know like what what
are you talking about but it's it's just
one of those little ideas it's one of
those little nods to like this is this
is Walt's story and and he's in this
place where he um he thinks he's got a
plan to uh solve all his problems yeah
absolutely and that's such a great great
line actually to encapsulate the whole
episode it's it's everything that we've
been talking about like he wakes up and
he's waking up to his potential and and
moving forward right like he's finally
ready to to take charge of his his life
he's feeling powerful he's feeling you
know more masculine and uh foreshadows
one of my favorite lines comes towards
the end of the series when he's talking
to Skyler in the kitchen and he tells
her that he was alive it's the same way
of saying that I think I'm awake I'm
alive yeah and it's the thing it's just
a human thing it's something that that
you can relate to because
part of life is getting you know running
into these kinds of situations I mean
luckily I I've never had to deal with
cancer
but I have I've had surprises that that
hit me like that and and that is the
that's the way you go you think hey I'm
going to solve this problem and
it's uh it just I just think that it's
one of the better uses of of that like
that look inside of the character that
we have in this episode that's just full
of them so what about you what is your
your top uh pick
so so that would have been my favorite
pick but since it's yours um my favorite
line would have to and I already spoke
about this a little bit earlier it's
also where we get the title of our
podcast it is his speech
um in front of the class when he says
that uh he sees a chemistry not as the
study of matter but as the study of
change I think that is such a important
line it really lets us know how to
understand this character and understand
the series that we are about to watch
yeah it's almost a little bit too on the
nose but I think it's not you know
because you don't really pick up on it
the first time you watch it because you
don't know who this guy is or or why
anything he's saying is important yet it
slides under the radar and then you
think about it later yeah yeah I don't
think watching it the first time time I
had that sort of insight it wasn't until
later you know but it is uh the perfect
description of what we witness
and uh what about favorite shot do you
have a favorite moment in the episode
yeah I I would have to say it's the shot
of the mustard stain on the doctor's
coat his his nice clean white coat
um mustard you know I I like mustard on
and you know but it's like one of those
things like when you get it on your hand
or your clothes it's a nightmare right
it's just like the the
the worst condiment when it comes to
that maybe and um
this is the situation where he's in he's
he's in this he's getting the worst news
a person can get he's dying
and it's one of those scenes that it
could go it could they could have really
played it up they could have really cued
the uh the score and they could have
really used it as a way to to pull on
your heartstrings and and really get you
on this guy's side and all those ways
that TV does you know that that they're
really good at doing and they went this
other direction and I think it is
fantastic and it's one of the things
that did hit me the very first time I
watched it I was like oh well that's
that's something like it caught my
attention
and um you know what I think that what I
you know thinking about it now I think
what really works about it for me is
there's you know characters can be
sympathetic because something bad is
happening to them you know that that's a
pretty that's pretty straightforward and
something that that that's a part of
every story
but this is this little situation in the
way that they filmed it and the way that
he is experiencing hearing this bad news
this makes me empathize with him you
know what I mean like this makes me
think about like getting the worst news
that I have ever got it's not the same
as as what his is but how that felt and
and and how how hard it can be to absorb
some bad news right something that you
don't want to hear that you don't want
to believe like that your body can't
even really
process which is what I feel like this
this is what this felt like to me when I
first saw this you know he's looking at
this
and there's there's a visual there's
visual things here too like the the
clean white coat the doctor is supposed
to be this you know elevated figure and
you see that mustard stain there it's
kind of like Walt himself the way he is
kind of becomes the the cancer in his
story you know and and how he uh kind of
stains everyone around him and
everything else but yeah that that
weirdness of the way that the
awkwardness of of him trying to to
process and then just focusing outward
on this on this imperfect like this
weird thing that's going on and
pulling it up and then just matter of
factly yeah I heard you uh history
cancer inoperable yep definitely I'm
gonna die maybe two years if I do the
the chemo it's very business right and
it highlights the absurdity of the
moments and and I think the the show
Runners really subverted expectations
this is a scene we've seen many many
times in TV shows and films a character
receives devastating news and as you say
the music swells and you know they they
get teary-eyed or whatever and it's
almost like we're being told that this
is an emotional scene you should feel
really bad but they feel something right
now yeah but they pull back right and
they let us feel for him the way we're
going to feel for him already and I
think that's one of the actually oddly
enough one of the reasons that makes him
even more empathetic right yeah
I would argue that this is the the point
where he goes from being just someone
that you feel sorry for but but someone
that you actually are fighting for you
know that you feel connected to on a
human level that you know you don't
necessarily that doesn't necessarily
happen until that point yeah agreed and
and it's that sort of um practicality of
Walt and his ability to compartmentalize
something else that we've been sort of
talking about
um throughout this this episode is uh
how he's able to separate what he does
at home what he does at school and like
what he's doing to make money right you
know being this this meth Kingpin and
how he is able to separate those
identities
um so much so that he invents this
character Heisenberg but as we see right
and something we've been talking about
and and contemplating was are these
really two separate identities or was
Heisenberg's there all along and um
there are a couple other moments that I
think also sort of speak to the
absurdity
um and and Walt's ability to regain
control right so I think of that moment
um right after uh it comes at the end of
the episode right but it's a picks up
where the the teaser ends right where
they're in the RV they've just crashed
and they have the bodies in the back of
the RV and Jesse comes to you and he
comes out and he walks up to 12 and he's
like what happened to them what'd you do
to him and he's like oh phosphine gas
and then he throws up right but then
he's like all right let's clean this up
you know it's very like he snaps right
back into
um you know what needs to be done so I
think it's it's a sort of really
interesting look at his character and
and how he's able to function and
process in in face of doing all these
horrible things like how is he able to
sleep at night in other words so we get
a glimpse of that with that little
mustard stain I think that is a really
great pick yeah what about you then what
is what is it did I probably stole it
again did I steal it or do you have
something different I have a couple
different things right and if I might
cheat a little bit here I kind of have
two moments I was having a hard time
deciding
um a monk because there's so many great
moments but one is in the same scene
that you're describing p and it's not so
much like a shot as it is the transition
I love the transition when he's on the
MRI machine you know getting scanned at
the hospital and then it cuts to his
reflection in the doctor's desk and then
we which is upside down just like he is
shot upside down on the MRI machine and
then the camera pans up to him and we
see him sitting there and he's got this
uh painting of the sandia's I'm assuming
it's mountains behind him on the the
wall and I was thinking about how that
also sort of uh calls forward to that
scene in front of the um the Credit
Union Mesa Credit Union when he pulls
out the money to buy the RV and that's
where your favorite line comes from
though I'm awake line so like I was
thinking of what what mountains
represent symbolically so we we talked
at the beginning of this podcast about
the landscape of Albuquerque being a
character but also mountains and what
they are symbolic for right so they are
these huge looming things that at least
historically have been representative of
like dreams and aspirations and also
conquering something right so it's like
a great challenge you can think of like
Hillary's Everest you know so being
faced with with an obstacle right and
there are a lot of obstacles so from
being diagnosed with cancer to you know
taking his life savings out to buy an RV
is this really going to work or is it
going to be a lucrative thing so I
really love those moments but probably
if I had to say like one favorite shot
it would have to be of Waltz in his tidy
whities he's got one tail like one side
of his shirt tucked into his underwear
that's a great detail to point out
because I I never really thought about I
mean I saw it a bunch of times and it
works perfectly but I never I never put
it into words and said them out loud
like you just did yeah so that scene of
him at the end of the episode again uh
picking up where the the cold open
um left off where he's holding the gun
and we're looking down the barrel of the
gun I mean can you think of a more
iconic shot really of the whole series I
mean that that became such an important
part of the series and an iconic and
representation yeah and I I know there's
something out there an interview with
Vince where he talks about how John Toll
try to talk him out of doing that just
because of the technical reasons and he
he decided to to argue with him and make
sure it stayed in there and I agree it
it does it's got more visual Flair than
than a lot of stuff in this but it I
think it works in this in this
particular instance to just you can't
forget it once you see it you can't
forget it it's part of your it's a part
of it's a part of the way that you that
you remember the show absolutely and you
know that's the genius of Vince Gilligan
I'm glad he didn't listen to John Toll
Oscar winner John told let's not forget
that part yeah but the and you you
touched on something there too about
um about how they made new the New
Mexico landscape a character how that
became such a big part of this and and
I'm sure that's something we'll talk
about
a lot throughout this first season and
throughout the series but
that's another one of those fun uh
circumstances one of those fun things
that happened like this was written to
be in Riverside California if you read
the the pilot
um it has nothing there's no mention
there was no idea to be in New Mexico
this was a situation where they got a
tax break for for shooting there and
they decided to to change it up and
yeah what would it be like if it wasn't
if they didn't have that I mean it's
such a good good thing and there's
another story there too about how Vince
he got the flu really bad while they
were shooting the pilot and he actually
had to leave for a few days so that just
left the crew
uh to go around and shoot a lot of the
you know a lot of um of the backgrounds
and the and the and the city and the
mountains and everything else and uh
that that probably made the the whole
like that the whole visual aesthetic it
probably helped develop that in a way
that that might not have happened if if
he hadn't got sick and had to go home
and couldn't shoot for a few days yeah I
mean tax breaks and flus uh are are you
know fortuitous in this case
um and more ways than one so yeah it is
interesting to think about how different
it would look had it been filmed
somewhere else I'm so glad they filmed
it in in New Mexico I'm so glad that
they did because it's one of the I can't
imagine it anywhere else I really can't
I mean how many shows have we seen in
California I mean California's beautiful
don't get me wrong but getting this
really novel landscape that you never
really got to see I mean outside of like
some of like the classic westerns uh we
don't really actually get to see this
landscape so there was something really
novel and interesting about it and again
just a sort of visual representation of
this bifurcation I've been talking about
so you have the Suburban uh you know
nicely like manicured yards cul-de-sac
suburbs of Albuquerque right where this
middle-aged man lives with his very
average middle class family living his
middle class life and then you're out in
the Wilds of the desert right where
where Heisenberg is is born so
um I think the landscape really like
really adds so much to that it really
does and I don't know if if any other
landscape would have worked as well yeah
and and uh you know I think that there
is so much more that we could talk about
here but I'm afraid that we might need
to wrap it all up what do you think yeah
I think that about does it there's
that we could say and that we will say
and we hope that you will join us next
week for our next episode and if you
would like to follow us on Twitter you
can find us at Breaking Bad gdt that's
gdt as in growth Decay transformation
and our email is breaking badgdt
gmail.com we would love to hear from you
yeah please send us some feedback if you
have questions we're not really sure how
we'll handle that but we'd love to hear
from you uh we're brand new at this as
you can tell so we want to get an idea
of what you guys want to hear and what
you think so far we do hope you'll join
us next week thanks for listening talk
to you soon